give me the most value you have three
pretty serious mentors Prince Puff Daddy
Big Boy give me three lessons each of
them
wow
um
Prince is like obviously like the
blueprint for
um
you know owning your you know
like as an artist not being afraid to
fight for what you were old on the
business side of things right
um and also creating a blueprint
um
that felt so free and
you could do anything you know and just
and just also speaking with him
he just always reminded me that
musically there was nothing that I could
not do
and I think with puff who has been a
person of his word
um you know we have a partnership
together when he had first heard me and
doing the science fiction singing about
that and you know I
doing doing whatever I wanted to do as
an artist creatively he always said like
I don't want to mess that up right I
just want the rest of the world to see
what I saw what I just saw tonight I
just want to help so I called him at a
really good time and
um you know he's just always been an
advocate for for me if I need to have
like
any business conversations I can I know
I can call him and you know listen to
him as well and then he just taught me
to just like be a fan of your own [__]
too you know promote your stuff if you
love it you got to promote your [__]
yeah yeah you worked hard and I think
with big boy big boy was just I mean I
got to give it to him you know the
reason why puffy even knew about me was
because of the work that big boy gave to
me I was thinking back up I was also on
Idlewild you know he was really really
promoting me with purple ribbon he
taught me the importance of I think
staying with family like screaming with
the people for like a little little bit
Yeah my lip but I always had my label
but I would do Partnerships yeah so it
was you was it was a Bubba spark yes
look at you a lot of people do not
remember killing my Killer Mike
Killer Mike's new album which is coming
out is it that one is it not out yet
okay I listened to it a couple weeks ago
okay it's incredible one of the greatest
rappers of all time oh I gotta I gotta
listen to it yeah it's incredible who
has the best parties Prince or Diddy oh
that's so tough ah because both of them
know how to [__]
it's different
I wonder if they I never went to a party
where they did it together
yeah it would explode like princess
daddy in the same party man because
you're gonna get music from like both of
them are gonna play the best music have
the most beautiful people there good
food
um
I don't know oh
listen uh which party would you rather I
believe the fifth I believe it okay
uh because it's good for different
reasons like for different reasons so
both both I'll say both I like that yeah